and i believe that to create a fruitful
ecosystem or to create
to to create a really meaningful
community you need to provide value
yeah not only to to the members but also
to people that
are kind of like trying to see how they
can partner with the community
[Music]
more amy thank you for joining me on my
show how are you
i'm very good thank you very much for
inviting me so
actually you're i think my first guest
that's talking from europe
uh right now right uh yes
at the moment i'm based in berlin based
in berlin okay well that's quite a quite
an interesting experience to be there
during covet
even though i believe that berlin
actually managed pretty well right from
the get-go right
definitely actually here it feels like
we're all almost back to the old normal
really okay that's well that's very
different from my usual base which is
either in california or tel aviv
uh both these places right now but you
know this will it'll take a few weeks
until we we publish this so let's hope
and that
that everyone will be great more you're
based in berlin you're working for
apx strategy and partnerships one of the
leading
early stage venture capitals and
accelerators and and you're running
relationships and
strategy so talk to me a little bit
about you know what you're doing at apx
how you even got to berlin
and then i'd love to go a little higher
you know 30 000 feet in the air and talk
about the
the european ecosystem for startups
so actually you ask one question but
with like
10 different questions 100 that's i love
doing that
i will try as a good israeli i will try
to answer
on your question and provide the the
answers that actually i want to give and
the information that i want to give
and so let's see how it works if i
forgot anything just let me know
sounds great so what is apx in general
apx is a joint venture of axel springer
which is the biggest european media
publisher
actually and not many people know and to
our israeli audience
they actually bought judge time oh wow
yes so of course there is an israeli
connection actually it's a very well
known
german company this always supports
israel
since a long long time ago and together
with porsche which is the german
automotive oem a luxury sports car
and and actually i started there
uh well while i was managing their
partnership with facebook
which is an i would say quite an
interesting um
what was that partnership how is
facebook connecting to
you know the startup ecosystem over
there so actually facebook has this kind
of like it's called the facebook
accelerator it exists all over europe
and also in israel
in berlin or in germany or in email i
don't want to i don't know what we want
to call it they
we were their local partners so actually
the aim
was to see how we can
help facebook integrate those their
technologies into
startups so we're not talking here about
ads or managing campaign ads
but actually more of like a bit more
well advanced technologies like alvr
a messenger um nai
and so we had quite an interesting
journey it was very journey it was like
weeks and working with the sea levels of
i would say
early stage startups but not that early
okay and
so that was i was that was i what i was
doing for the last six months
and then recently um i
joined i kind of like stayed and shifted
my position a little bit
towards a strategic partnership and
growth
okay and just to make it kind of like
keep it simple so basically
my job is to understand how i position
atx not only
europe-wise as the leading early-stage
investor but also in israel
and other ecosystems and in parallel to
that
to create business business
opportunities for our portfolio
that is currently with over 50 companies
from actually all over the world
that's awesome okay so what does that
mean you know how do you go about
and and taking a vc or or an accelerator
that and taking it from europe and
trying to get it based in israel and try
to get you know
get in on the good deals and become you
know a well-known brand
so that israeli startups instead of
going to some of the other well-known
vcs
they they would consider going to apx
for their c or series a
if you have the answers please please
let me know because that's actually what
i'm trying to do
um but in a nutshell maybe it's kind of
like also
connected to who i am and where i'm
coming from so
i'm originally israeli was born and
raised in israel
and was working quite a lot in the
israeli ecosystem
and you were working with mobility right
you had something yeah
i i started my career with the ecomotion
which is the biggest
smart mobility community uh in israel
and later on i um worked for a hubraam
which is the city investment vehicle of
deutsche telekom
so i guess i always had the german kind
of like
bug inside of me um
and then after yeah after those
positions i decided okay it's about time
to kind of like
see what else out there outside of the
israeli ecosystem bubble which is very
comfortable
but i felt it was too comfortable for me
and
and i believe in actually creating value
i mean i'm
in my kind of like core i'm a community
manager that's how i started
and i believe that to create a fruitful
ecosystem or to create
to to create a really meaningful
community you need to provide value yeah
not only to to the members but also to
people that
are kind of like trying to see how they
can partner with the community
and that's exactly how i see this
position as well i feel like
okay it's apx it's kind of like a joint
venture of two well-known names
in the i would say not only in the
german ecosystem but in the
worldwide ecosystem if i can call it
that way
but what makes us different than other
vcs or other programs that are out there
and it's actually the value that we can
provide to the companies
and i think that although we have this
kind of like you know
corona crisis and it might be more
challenging to raise
money but good companies will approach
vcs that not only can give them the
money but can also give them the
connection
and the kind of like i would say the
unique selling point
it can be connections it can be um
i don't know good advice or feedback or
support helping them to get new
customers and that's kind of like what
i'm trying to do in the position
because we do provide money but what
else do we provide
amazing so you know i'm fairly i'm
fairly um
you know um comfortable within the
you know the the silicon valley
ecosystem the tel aviv ecosystem in
terms of you know
how startups operate and the different
stages that they go through i'm very
excited to go on that journey myself
pretty soon and in in both fields but i
i know nothing about the european
ecosystem and
obviously some say that israel is part
of europe but um but you know the real
european ecosystem and you know
germany and in berlin and the places
that you get to work at
how how do startups operate there is it
different
than in palo alto or tel aviv is there a
different mindset
are the investment stages the same talk
a little bit about that
so first of all when you say europe i
mean
it's it's pretty challenging to say
europe and then
kind of like try to generalize it yeah
i'm sure yeah even in germany
the berlin ecosystem doesn't look like
the ecosystem in munich or in frankfurt
interesting so maybe if we will that's
why when i kind of like talked to
startups and they're like yeah we see
europe is kind of like our
next destination okay what is europe is
it yeah
is it france is it the netherlands is it
mostly cultural
is it mostly cultural norms or
professional norms that are different i
think it's all together
but one thing i can say that i think
that if you manage to
conquer germany in a way you as a
startup have
a good reputation because germany is
well known to being a bit of a tough
market here and i think not only for
foreign startups but also for german
startups themselves
and i will now kind of like maybe
very much generalize it just for the
second of the conversation but it goes a
bit
deeper than that but germans if i would
say
but like that compared to israelis are
less than to take risks
right and if a small company from israel
come and say knock on the door and say
hey hello we have this great technology
we've been to
8 200. i'm sure you heard about this um
and uh you know we're going to rev
review or revolutionize the way that i
don't know
you are um protecting your
data let me kind of like show you how we
do it
so don't be surprised that they say if
they're very polite and say
thank you but we don't need you at the
moment yeah or they don't even bother to
answer the email
interesting i think what's really
important in germany is actually to make
sure
that when you come here you know exactly
what is it that you want to get
you are pretty stable finance wise
and but also have the capacity to
actually
deliver what it is that you promise
and i know that in the israeli ecosystem
we always say of course we can do it in
14 days you will have it
but when it come yours you can't save 14
days and then deliver it in like
right six months yeah it doesn't work
like that and you need to come when you
have
caballot when you have invoices when you
are like okay
that's what i was doing so far now
here that's how i see how i can optimize
that or help you to achieve that
don't try to find a kind of like you
know how you're going to change the
entire structure
because germans also don't like changes
for years
their economy is working the industry is
kind of like moving
you can come there and promise them
something that you both know you won't
be able to deliver
so try to be a bit modest i would say
and also come prepared that is going to
take
be a long process um
but the minute you manage to create this
kind of like confidence
so they will see you as a long-term
client or
customer right actually you're going to
walk this
road together for a long time so you
know it's also different than the u.s
right so you know in both in the u.s and
in israel it's also very accepted that
you know big corporates
are partners with startups and they're
very supportive of startups not only do
they have often venture arms
to invest in starters but they often
bring them in and and
and do these do these you know initial
contracts pretty leniently
similarly ex c-level executives on a lot
of these companies are angel investors
themselves or they sit on the boards
of startups themselves is that existent
in the german echo
ecosystem do german corporates have an
arm where
they help startups do the executives
invest and sit on the boards or is that
different as well
um so actually it's a very interesting
question and i think that in israel
it's very small ecosystem and it has its
own its own rules
yeah but it's also a bit far away from
the headquarters
and eventually when you kind of like
approach this corporate you start with
kind of like playing in the israeli
ecosystem
but it does not promise that you will
take a
core part in what the mission or
strategy of the headquarters and that's
what i was doing in
deutsche telekom i was basically their
woman on the ground and helped to source
startups that might be potentially
strategically relevant for hubham
and i can tell you it's super
challenging
eventually you need to understand what's
the strategy that the corporate need not
even now
maybe in two three years and then to
understand who within this corporate
will be able to kind of like lead you in
this i would say
very sometime complicated roads within
the corporate
and and actually that's something that i
was trying to solve here because i
realized
that we the israeli ecosystem i think
it's amazing
the way it helps and provides support
and knowledge sharing
to the all the members all the different
members of the ecosystem and here in
berlin
i felt it was a bit missing it's also
important to say that
it's not like you cannot really compare
the israeli ecosystem in berlin to the
one in
silicon valley or in london in other
places because it wasn't
that developed only in the roof like few
last years you can see more and more
israelis that actually comes here
to work in startups and work with big
companies and big corporates
and together with a friend and a partner
we created here
a community for israelis in tech and
business
and the aim was actually to kind of like
create this small israeli ecosystem
where you create connection helps to
network and provide
tip advice or even just kind of like
support to anyone in needs
so we have more than 200 members coming
from the different corporates in germany
startups government israeli companies
that are based here
and because indeed it's very very
tough so yeah kind of like into this
market and say
hey okay what's next and sometimes you
just need to hear a little hebrew and to
have a little
fun and have a beer with friends but
more you know
why are you doing this because you know
it sounds very complicated it sounds
tough
it sounds like you know this is a
developing area that you know it's
there's a lot of
you know you really have to understand
the different players and it's not
necessarily as
open yet as in a lot of other areas why
why are you over there instead of you
know being in silicon valley or in or in
tel aviv
um it's an interesting question and i
sometimes ask myself the same question
hey what happened like you can stay in
tel aviv and you know
do your thing and everything will be
fine and you want us to struggle with
germans and with the
language and with the culture but i
think that those kind of like
outside of comfort zone spaces where you
can grow
the most i mean the level of connections
and
experience that i gained here in less
than three years is tremendous
i don't think i could ever be able to
create something like that
not only in israel but in other places
that are a bit maybe a bit more mature
than the
ecosystem here and i think that that
also gives me an opportunity to grow
within the ecosystem
and actually to position myself in a
place that
i kind of like can create new things
and initiate different projects that
actually like no one saw before and i
can say that
many of the things that i was doing it's
something it's like those things that i
got from the israeli ecosystem and the
way we work
um and it's super fun i feel it's like
okay it's a new playground
yeah and i bring my skills but
i also had the experience and the
opportunity to learn and get to know
other culture
which in the world of today i think it's
something you can't learn
like you know through computer or with
making video calls you actually have to
be here
and understand how this ecosystem
operates
and also how different people create
different kind of businesses and
relations
um and sometime when i'm i'm visiting
israel i need to kind of like you know
do this kind of like shift in mind i'm
like okay here
you don't cue you need to like go from
that side if you or
do you know to be a bit more louder if
you want to get what is it that you want
so it's a different mindset and it's
like for me it's
amazing to be kind of like get this
exposure to what
i'm having here and also to be this kind
of like channel when israeli companies
or people that kind of like
also want to experience i can be the
person that kind of like say hey you can
do that and that
because it's something that i myself did
it that's so so cool so did kovit hit
you know the german ecosystem the same
way that it hit the other world in terms
of know everybody going to remote
working and startups
having trouble raising money was it a
similar
similar thing in your area
um i would say yes or no i think that
here we need to divide it
and also to different kind of like
aspects i think that the german
government was
well prepared and to what is about to
come
and many startups at this kind of like
or many not only startups many companies
in general in the german industry
have what is called courts albeit and
which is
the company still exists and the
government pays
60 to 70 of the employee's salary wow so
actually companies didn't fire anyone
oh wow they're still working yes amazing
that's amazing yeah so the economy is
still
moving and and i think that create kind
of like
a bit less stressful situation i can
tell you that at
apx we actually invested in more than
five companies
during since i would say corona started
hit us all in at the beginning of march
so we continue to invest money in
startups
and we also see that i mean
it's not that you know corner hit and
then suddenly you kind of like stop
everything some of the process
started it before that so in for many of
those
giant companies and big big companies
it's not like a matter of k over months
or two i'm going to change my entire
strategy
something that the budget and the plan
was deployed long time ago
so you kind of like keep moving some of
the companies
actually said okay we're not going to
hire new people at the moment
but the ecosystem is still moving
that's okay like everyone else we
adapted ourselves to kind of like be an
online world but i have to admit that
last week i was actually in a physical
event
wow okay that's a little slightly that's
a little scary in my mind
yeah yeah i have you know one of the
things that i was contemplating with
friends was that we're watching you know
netflix now
and all of a sudden you see on in the
movie you know two people hugging or
shaking hands and i'm like oh my god
look no you can't there's a pandemic
what are you doing uh so it's it's i
think it's it's a really interesting
thing that's happening now but but more
do you see yourself
all you know long term in this
relationship between
germany and and israel or is this
something that you're like wow like i
had this amazing five years now i'm
ready to go
and now i'm ready to go back to tel aviv
or to my next
to my next country for an adventure
so maybe i i should ask you that
question if someone would ask you like
six months ago would you ever imagine
that we will have
no flights we won't be able to leave our
home and restaurants are bar are going
to be closed
would you imagine that so i guess not
and i guess that's life
for me it feels like you know i can plan
and decide
how is it that i see my future or what
i'm going to do in five years
but reality prove us that we can't plan
that long so at the moment i'm having
fun
and i feel that i'm being challenged and
learn
new things and actually i can grow
i can grow here yeah i get that
at some point i know myself i need to
kind of like change
and whenever i feel too comfortable
i know that it's about time to live so
when i feel like that maybe
i will make the change but let's see i
guess
wonderful more before we leave i want to
ask you know you you get to see all
these startups and you get to see these
different ecosystems
do you notice any things that are there
are perhaps you know lagging in terms of
the ecosystem that you're in some
technologies that you know we already
consider mainstream
in you know in different parts of the
world that are potential opportunities
for young entrepreneurs
who are considering you know their next
steps and maybe there's a good
opportunity in europe or specifically in
germany
so i think in general the startups the
startup material here is a bit different
than what you see maybe i'll say
tel aviv because i'm not very familiar
with what's going on in silicon valley
here and i would be precise and say
berlin because i don't want to
like talk about the rest of germany
because as i mentioned it's a bit
different
startups here are less technology
innovative
but more of like business model or
product innovation you can see
a lot of consumer products a lot of b2c
and which is actually quite interesting
and in israel you can see a lot of deep
tech so
kind of like companies that it will take
them five to seven years until we will
or
very very long life cycles of cells
until you can actually
see something and here it's a bit
different i mean
you can see that the big unicorns the
german uranicorns are
marketplaces for cars auto irons salando
which is kind of like the german assets
and get your guide which is marketplace
for traveling or
tourism and it's not by accident i mean
you need that's what i'm saying that i
don't think it's kind of like a
different
world but the way technology perceived
here is a bit different than what we see
in israel
in israel we're very much used to say
okay we're going to change the
the way that i don't know we drive our
car and everything is super super
oriented technology-oriented yeah we're
here it's a bit
different but you can also see the
success
very fast of those products or the
failures and
fascinating so i would say that
i think it's a great place um
to come here after you have some i would
say products
validation and technology validation but
it's not
a very good place for experimentation
so i would recommend unless you are very
like
mobility and then like you know all the
oem and tier ones are this is the
perfect place for you and also depends
which kind of like what is it in the
mobility that you are doing
come here when you already kind of like
have some funding
product market fit a bit more kind of
like stability in the company
and my maybe my my
tip will actually be that to have
someone that is physically here
although we all live in zoom i think
that germans
and it's very very important to have
someone on the ground that you can talk
contact with and if he's german and
local it's sometimes
even better and because although we kind
of like
say yeah you know we are swiss knives
israelis we can do everything
everywhere there is kind of like it's
it's crucial to have someone here and if
that someone speaks german and not only
the language but the culture life would
be easier
that that that really sounds interesting
more thank you so much for your time
again for your generosity before we
leave i need three words
that you would use to describe yourself
so that's going to be a tricky one
i'll do my best so i would say israeli
okay red head and white wine
israeli redhead and white wine i love it
more toda thank you very much and best
of luck with everything
bye bye thank you